today we're looking at a portrait of  antio boizios she's a german marine  biologist and director of the alfred  wegener institute  that was at the helm of a unprecedented  expedition into the arctic  researching climate change there so  helinda what's the story behind this  portrait  anti-british were very much influenced  by the  adventure story of her grandfather he  was a sailor  and had many many many stories and  dangerous stories to tell but also she  was influenced by her mother and  grandmothers  two strong women and they told her  that for girls everything is possible  and as a child she also wanted to be a  astronaut of the earth interior  and she fulfilled her and  was 30 years on ships and made 49  expeditions  she also recognized that you have to  create  new big ideas not to work and little  things  and her philosophy is also give the  coincidence  a chance in your life